right Alan yeah while we're waiting then
to finish cooking okay where did you
learn to cook cuz you quite a good
talented cook on no I'm not no I got
I've never gone not good oh I mean I
could make stars now not like as good as
this forgot the [ __ ] egg yolk oh
where did that coming
what well that meant it to help to sort
of bind them together ah yours give it a
little bit more crumbly Amano hosters
Nelson now you and Justin Lee Collins
are a bit of a double knock joke each
other now we are going out eating
together we love curries we actually
love carries my favourite thing and then
before we are we hope that before oh
look there's a great lot of food sucking
his booty daddy does pick it all up
that is scary I don't like that I was
Cathy really yeah fantastic get your
lime okay cut the lime in half okay Kay
and what we can do now is squeeze that
line okay over the cabarrus now that
just makes it so much more vibrant more
importantly really helps for sort of
moisturized yes yeah and you can
identify the sort of smells the flavors
and the whole thing just becomes alive
nice oh no so right no nice good with
the egg without without really messy I
won't tell them okay
there'll be a little bit crumbly but
it.we fine now lift them out the pan
nice and carefully put two on your
spatula at a time okay
nice and gentle as you carry them over
and the secret here of course this is to
serve these nice and hot now good - up
mmm get a mother huh
that's a spatula you got a fish dice or
me gasps no I didn't put the egg in I
want him to be gluten-free right your
sauce now yogurt sauce yep
okay a nice generous spoonful I think
the side of each plate yeah
and there we have yeah okay the most
amazing lamb Shami kabab done